[Music]
in daddy's girl news daddy's girl
submitted by Tristan from Kansas and up
Tristan I like that name just gets this
this reminds me of a Power Ranger
Tristan Tristan from Kansas a
father/daughter couple has been arrested
for incest after having a love child
yeah oh [ __ ]
wait it's punishable by crying in some
state on some states right yeah well not
in West Virginia you know it's just the
stereotype so I'm not sure they don't
really mention exact ages but I do know
she's over the age of 18 so this man
they're from North Carolina hmm so he
had a daughter with his wife right his
daughter his name is Katie can I guess
what happened
Joey okay did they get separated
when she was young like the wife and the
husband divorce and then she lives with
a mom and then years later they met up
and found each other and fell in love
because that's a thing that happens like
it's a chemical thing where like if
you've been separated your biological
father and then you meet up later in
life you like connection yeah there's a
connection and like yeah there's like we
did it we did one where a guy I mean a
father and a daughter connected after
yeah but he never knew her and if they
never knew each other yeah they wanted
to start a new relationship like as
daddy-daughter and then they started
[ __ ] yeah that's exactly but I never
connected with my daddy in that way well
they got divorced and then for like the
first couple years I couldn't see them
I'm glad when I did see them hey hey I
like the way will you choose with your
mouth open mind the way you make your
dumplings bah bah bah
so Steven and his wife they ended up
giving Katie up for adoption so when
Katie turned 18 back in 2016
she found her parents via social media
there the parents are still together
they ended up having two more kids and
kind of weird so then Katie ended up
moving into the home with the whole
family and shortly after her moving in
the wife moved out and the wife points
out that in the month before the wife
moved out the husband would sleep in
Katie's bedroom floor and she didn't
think that was we're just reading
bedtime stories
butt-naked with a dick I don't think
that's weird like unless they started
[ __ ] I agree it's not [ __ ] they
started I believe that's the exact
problem that they're happening when
you're not sleeping with his wife at
night is pretty weird that's very weird
that is weird though that is we do each
other he just it's not weird if they're
arguing it's very good it's still weird
cuz now you're not just sleeping on the
couch you're sleeping in the role okay
okay then who you just met routine now
too because I was thinking they were
close now like stuff it's been years but
then you're right it's only been like a
couple years yeah no not even a couple
years ooh a couple months no they're
[ __ ] they're [ __ ] we made a full
circle yeah I flew in in May last year
the wife was reading in the journal one
of her children that Katie was pregnant
and that the dad with the dead
so then oh sure because she was saying
something about like I saw the news on
this that like the little girl was
saying um daddy's making me call her
stepmom yeah so he was make yeah the dad
was making the others Laura's all cover
call his oldest daughter
that's like not only are you my sister
you're my mom to any when the baby comes
out hey grandpa dad is it grandpa first
or dad first
oh it's confusing yeah dad
just call him wizard dad pop how old is
the dead and they don't mention it
because if they had the kid like get
like 17 or 16 and then it'd be like an
18 year old with like a 34 year old or
36 year old yeah that's true you know
what probably happened you know how like
sometimes your kids look like you
sometimes and then it probably looked
like a younger version of his wife and
the days you made me feel so yeah so
then the wife confronted the husband
about it and he said yes I am gonna be
you know the father of my grandchild the
father of my because it sounds like shut
your mouth or no talking to me 42 she's
20 found that found the agents okay the
dads 42 the daughters 20 I am gonna be
the father of my nephews nieces yeah
better than your daughters being the dad
of your daughters son yeah that's a
weird [ __ ] did I remember when this
happened we were asking the question
like would you rather be with the one
that's biologically yours like your your
kid but then you have you never known
them for all of your life or the one
that's not biologically yours and then
but but you known them all your life
which was I thinking what stuff what do
you know them all your life is worse
because that's what I say that was weird
no because like you're raising them as
your child the whole time and like
that's even though they're not blood
like that's like yet the relationship is
parental whereas like the one you
haven't met before it's like meeting a
stranger
yeah bottle my kid had come out with
like a third Plus ears oh no that's the
work you don't have a kid with them
because that's not you
okay with them yeah I thought you're
talking just romantically romantically
yeah
so then they later on went off she looks
like oh what's the Brenda Elana two of
them oh yeah she looks way too young
yeah yeah
I'm not yeah she looks like kind of a
Jenny she has that Japanese skincare
routine going on yeah Japanese getting
married the dad looks kind of like a
vampires before they got caught okay
I'll tell ya and then they had a baby
boy the other birth defects I'm not sure
yeah look at that face this is crazy
I know like if you're it'd like
blood-related like first blood but that
looks like like they're so what is the
wife thinks she's just like oh whatever
he left me for our kid like you're the
weird thing about this is most people
will have the shame and but they're
celebrating the shape they've hired a
photographer and they they have yeah
they're telling the kids like the dad is
saying hey call your sister stepmom now
but like they never knew her as a sister
growing up so it's just like okay the
stranger that we invited in our house
she's our stepmom now I hope that's how
it was all right that is just so good
not like this is your long-lost sister I
don't know if I'll be able to face my
kid after giving them up for adoption
you know they're like hey I want to meet
I'm like sorry but you're assuming that
you're giving them up for a selfish
reason maybe it's because financially
you were or you were like I don't know
you just couldn't take care of a baby
yeah I still don't want to see them they
turn later they trying to [ __ ] up my
flow of my life all right
what if they became NBA basketball
player that's much that's my baby
[Laughter]
parents dude that's exactly what they
did really like her mom gave him up or
some [ __ ] and that's that every [ __ ]
gay oh my god
or Justin Bieber right because his dad
was kind of like not really there and he
started coming around after the fact
yeah those people like praising his sons
dignity so weird oh yeah so they are
both charged with incest with adult
adultery contribute and contributing to
delinquency because they had warrants
and then they fled quickly adultery is a
crime yeah in some state I thought it
was how do adultery I was like a moral
thing no in some states is considered a
misdemeanor and even a few states are
considered a felony Wow so if you're
married and you do - cheater YZ yeah I
[Laughter]
mean living in secular California you
know it was just something like it was
just a way to get more alimony like if
they cheated on you then you definitely
get alimony well in certain states it is
illegal so much because you're breaking
the institution of mileage that's why
it's a sacred thing it would be in one
of those like butter turning States
right butter churning lots they don't
have electricity of [ __ ] it's just
obvious people people were that where
they live that's where it would be
illegal
you get stoned over there if you are
yeah if you wake up with a different
dick in your mouth or a [ __ ] whatever
a [ __ ] they even do that a [ __ ] in the
vagina yeah so you know what after they
reproduce gee I don't know what's going
on right now but I don't know they might
think it's a sin to put a dick in their
mouth oh yeah you mean oral sex yeah
isn't in the Bible thou shalt not sodomy
years ago you can't bother me can't do a
sex yeah well you turn into a pillar of
salt
really yeah it's the story of the story
story story I'm Sodom and Gomorrah oh
because I don't have a because I don't
have a sister
or a daughter yet oh I don't think I'll
ever have a sister
the closest thing I could like relate to
is like my cousins and close female
friends right
and it's really like the longer I get to
know someone it's like they're no longer
a part of the potential [ __ ] pool
yeah yeah so it they turn into like oh
you're you're differently like a wall
you're like not even you're a soul yeah
and it doesn't matter how beautiful how
pretty it's it's just it's different
yeah so I don't know how people can do
that it's like you raise a daughter and
then like you know you you grow with
them and then like you still want to
[ __ ] them but this guy didn't raise it
oh yeah I forgot about that yeah like a
stranger like yeah he's just like oh you
soldier you look like me with long hair
I just think it's dangerous with the
having a kid thing cuz like the there's
a lot of like birth defects and like
chromosome defects that happen with when
you do that yeah I don't know that's
kind of weird gonna grow up and gonna
know that his mom oh yeah for sure like
if I was a kid like that was five years
old and I find out about him I'm
definitely making fun I'm bullying him
for sure well I'm a five year old kid
you don't blame me
I'm innocent to do but to their defense
royal families did this all the time
yeah exactly is where they know
[Music]